the top business store is live from the
Sky News City Studio
10th water secures an additional 750
million pounds from shareholders lesser
than it was looking for
BT confirms its sieching seeking a new
chief executive after the incumbent
Philip Johnson said he intends to step
down
our new research suggests that details
of more than a third of all Global
mergers and Acquisitions leak
[Music]
good morning this is a business live
with Ian King and Thames water has this
morning announced that its shareholders
will inject a further 750 million pounds
worth of equity into the business during
the next two years well the cash
injection comes on top of the half a
billion pounds that investors put into
the company in March temp set a further
two and a half billion pounds would need
to be raised between 2025 and the end of
the decade well the news came as Thames
reported an underlying pre-tax loss of
82.6 million pounds for the year to the
end of March that was done for a loss of
935.6 million pounds during the previous
12 months the company also revealed that
its debt pile Grew From 12.9 billion
pounds to 13.9 billion pounds During the
period Well tens water couldn't bring
themselves to speak to us today but
joining me now is Alan Smith he's an
industry consultant who's previously
worked for seven Trent water South West
water and Yorkshire water Alan welcome
to you
um clearly Thames has been able to raise
some Equity but we heard from or fought
last week they were looking for a
billion they haven't raised that
no it's it's the boogers modeling to be
honest with you they they not only
Thames but the industry is in a mess I
think it's complacency It's a
combination of greed arrogance uh
particularly at the board level by the
way not for the 50 000 guys that uh run
and manage brilliantly well the
treatment work etc but uh the way that
the industry's managed the way that the
industry is regulated is is just not fit
for purpose it's a broken model and
things need to change and they don't
need to have elastoplast and sticky tape
which is what we've heard this morning
we need something that's sustainable for
the future and the only way to go is to
get the new model in and get rid of this
lot
would that mean nationalization
no not at all no I've been there Ian I
mean I I spent half of my career in the
public sector and when when
privatization came in in 89 it was
brilliant it was exciting there was a
huge injection of cash an investment
that was not there before progressively
over the period though 10 years or so
the industry became complacent of what
became massively inconsistent and is now
totally inappropriate in my view and so
the whole thing is slipped down to
short-termism
expediency and and really not fit for
purpose not for long-term investment
which is what the industry is all about
well that's a very good point I mean how
does one get new investment into this
sector when it's been so egregiously
managed well let me tell you what what
we should do and I've said this in a
release I did yesterday uh defra should
get around the table with the treasury
with off walked and devise and look at
the way that we can and give
compensation to the current shareholders
of the current broken model we should
then introduce a highly successful model
which Welsh water have now been in
operation with uh since 2000 over 20
years it's proved very successful it's
not for profit uh it makes surpluses
those surpluses go back into capital
investment and treatment works Etc and
the customer and this is really
important Joe public thinks that it's a
great move and they've got much closer
to their customers than they did do in
the years before
you mentioned just now Alan that you
thought that uh what off what was unfit
for purpose
um it's quite interesting to know that
thames's new co-chief executive is a
formal director general of off what
should that sort of thing be allowed no
no it shouldn't uh and don't tell me
they're not liaising one another with
one another on a fairly regular basis so
there's no arms length there and and
that complacency leads to the sort of
inefficiency that we've got I mean bear
in mind Ian that in the past decade of
what were all about scrambling around to
reduce bills and that of course was at
the behest of the government and defra
now uh they're being told oh no we need
to we need to invest a lot more now for
this who overflows etc etc under the
pressure so the inconsistency is
phenomenal and you cannot have
inconsistency in a long-term business in
a long-term industry that depends on
regular and consistent water supplies
and so treatment for 60 million
customers not fit for purpose time to go
now among the shares of Thames water
right now is the University's
superannuation scheme which of course
runs the retirement Savings of thousands
of University lecturers and uh teachers
up and down the country how worried
should they be about their Equity State
being potentially wiped out
I I'm not so sure they'll be wiped out
and I'm sure there will be some sort of
a compromise but but you know let the
buyer beware uh if you're into an
industry that 70 of which is owned
overseas you you have to expect that
there might be issues and there might be
risk and that's something that they
they've got to look at but my view is if
I was in their position and I was their
chairman I'd be looking for a new
investment as quickly as I could yeah I
mean this is the interesting thing isn't
it they wanted a billion they've only
raised 750 million I mean clearly
there's a tolerance to what shareholders
are going to accept and perhaps maybe
reluctant to throw good money after bad
well of course it is and of course the
reason they're in the pickle that
they're in is that they initially didn't
borrow enough or Equity enough and 70 as
you know is is debt which is index
linked which puts them in the position
that they're in today so it's been very
very poorly managed very very poorly
regulated and I've got to say by an
interfering government that really
doesn't know which way to turn
that's an interesting point why'd you
say that
uh defra is not fit for purpose I mean
it's a weak organization look at look at
where they are now I don't want to name
names but I mean look at the head
Teresa coffee I mean come on
I mean she's been in the job about 60
days I think uh she doesn't know the
water industry we we're lacking now at
that level especially within the death
recorders of people who actually
understand and know the industry so they
move from crisis to crisis I mean for
example they they plan for water
shambles in in April was a regurgitation
of many things that they've been looking
at before and to be honest with you the
select committees so the know what you
know that the blame can be shared around
here you look at the select committees
from Parliament they they they're just
not fit for purpose either I mean you
get the likes of Sir Robert Goodwill
saying at the weekend about off what oh
have they been asleep at the wheel uh uh
have they been very complacent in my
view they have as Southern Waters credit
rating than the way it's gone down it
does seem rather Reckless come on I mean
that's like being hit with a dead fish I
mean something needs to happen and in
the Palaces of Westminster you know that
sleepy lot needs to get together and to
look for and certainly look at the Welsh
water model which has been highly
successful it's not for profit it
delivers and the customers are delighted
so time for change here and can't come
soon enough Alan it's been suggested
that uh that the publicly quoted water
companies the likes of penong group
which owned South West Water Seven Trent
they've been rather less badly run over
the years than the likes of Thames water
which of course have privately held and
have sit behind these very opaque
financing structures is there a case for
saying that all of the water companies
should be at least partially listed on
the stock market in the name of
transparency
well I think I think with any large uh
infrastructure industry as this is there
are going to be good players they're
going to be bad players but but let me
just take a step back from that Ian what
does Joe public want a guy who turns a
tap on and flushes the loop does he want
profit to be made out of a monopoly
company on an essential service and
essential for life service the answer is
and he's told us since 1989 79 of the
public did not want profits dividends
and shareholders in a company that
provided such an essential service today
after 200 billion pounds of investment
and I was involved in a lot of that uh
it's 83 so the public do do not want it
so scratching around with those that you
know I think that's tinkering around
with the model that's broken looking at
what might be less uh unfavorable than
another is not the way forward
I think in a water industry and as I say
I've been in it for 50 plus years and
I've worked in the public sector and the
private sector so I've seen the good and
the bad of both but my view is that the
compromise between those two is the
not-for-profit and Welsh water have done
the testing and it's been highly
successful
okay Alan gotta leave it there
appreciate you joining me today thank
you okay take care
some other business news stories for you
now and BT confirmed this morning that
it's begun the search for its new chief
executive confirming a story broken by
Sky's Mark glyman at the weekend BT said
the current CEO Philip Johnson had
indicated he planned to step down at
some point during the next year he's
been in the role since February 2019.
well among those being tipped us to
successor and mark alera the head of
BT's consumer arm and Alison Kirkby a
non-executive director of BT who's
currently chief executive of the
Scandinavian telecoms group telia
the medicines and Healthcare products
regulatory agency the UK's medicines
regulator has approved gsk's vaccine for
Respiratory sexual virus or RSV the mhra
authorized GSK shots which is called RXV
to be used to immunize patients against
lower respiratory tract disease caused
by the virus well RSV causes thousands
of hospitalizations and deaths annually
it normally presents as cold-like
symptoms but it's a leading cause of
pneumonia in toddlers and the elderly
and the student accommodation provider
unite group said this morning that
reservations for the 2023-24 academic
year were at record levels the company
which has nearly 28 000 beds in 71
properties across 19 University towns
and cities said 98 of rooms were now
sold for the year unite also said that
us at the end of June its property
portfolio was independently valued at
2.92 billion pounds that was up for 1.2
percent on the position at the end of
March
well we're just going to briefly step
away from the business news at the
moment to uh the breaking news from
Tewkesbury I can show you some of the
first pictures that have come in from
Tewkesbury school which has been placed
into lockdown after a teenager was
arrested after a teacher was stabbed at
the secondary school gloucestershire
police have said that an adult has been
taken to hospital with a suspected Stab
Wound the four said officers were called
at around 10 past nine on Monday this
morning to reports that a pupil had
stabbed the teacher and a teenage boy
has been arrested more on that as we get
it
foreign
[Music]
Equity markets in the Asia Pacific
region saw mixed trade overnight
following declines further declines on
Wall Street on Friday afternoon the
Nikkei in Tokyo fell for a fifth
consecutive session well in Europe
stocks have started the week on a
largely positive note here's the current
pitch only uh the Ibex in Madrid in
negative territory right now talking
points this morning include Julius Barr
the wealth manager is up one percent
after its CEO gave a bullish interview
with the German newspaper handles black
that of course is a company listed in
Zurich we're here in London the ftse 100
is in positive territory albeit only by
a tenth of one percent helped by a rally
in some of the energy stocks flutter
entertainment is the leading percentage
again there looks to be a few bargain
hunters coming out of the woodwork after
last week's declines to a six-month low
outside the ftse the online trading
platform plus 500 is ahead by some two
percent on a trading update while the
publisher future is ahead by seven
percent after announcing a share buyback
plan worth up to 45 million pounds the
legal Services provide a Knights group
meanwhile we've had the CEO of that
company on the program in the past
they're up six and a half percent on a
trading update but the healthcare
services provider totally is down by 25
and that is on a downbeat trading
statement on the foreign exchange
markets well the dollar has recovered
some of its Poise after Friday afternoon
sell-offs accordingly Sterling is off by
just over a third of one percent against
the Greenback it's also off by a quarter
one percent against the Euro The single
currency meanwhile off by tenth of one
percent against the dollar as for the
oil price well that enjoyed a solid gain
last week but it's become this week
trading to the downside about it Brent
crude will currently set you back 78
dollars seven cents a barrel that's a
little over half of one percent lower on
the session well joining me now is the
investment director AJ Bell Ross mold
Ross good to see you this morning thank
you so Philip Johnson's uh leaving BT a
bit of a surprise this or not really
there was no real information but
beforehand but he's coming up to five
years in office and that's exactly bang
on the average for current Futsal 100
CEO those so you can maybe say okay no
great surprise there and in some ways he
might be quite pleased to get out the
back door because you look at the share
price while he's been in charge it's
more or less halved and at 120 P or
there or there they're back to where
they were in December 1984 straight
after the thatch of privatization so
it's been it's in some ways you have to
feel for BT it's got the regulator
breathing fire on one side it's got lots
and lots of competition in Broadband in
Wireless in TV and customers who are
very willing and able to switch around
so it's very you know kind of cabin
encrypted and confined on Old fronts
effectively and that's why the share
price has done what it's done despite Mr
Johnson's best efforts with the
discovery sport merger and all of those
things absolutely I mean it's fair to
say he has done a pretty good job hasn't
he I mean he has you know he's reached a
settlement with the regulator that
they're building out at open reach as
fast as they possible reinstated the
dividend I think under the circumstances
he's done what he could but I think you
know and there's lots of comment on
regulations where they've done a good or
a bad job I think from a consumer's
perspective in telecoms right now the
customer is probably getting the better
end of it than the sharehold are in the
company yes BT's case now this evening
we had the mansion house speech there's
a lot of stuff coming down the pipeline
with implications for the investment
industry what do you make of what you've
been reading yeah I think the thing on
digital shares is is frankly something
that's been in process for a very very
long time nobody really wants to run the
risk of having a shoe box under the bed
and the paper certificates get lost and
most private investors now own their
shares through retail investment
platforms so it's a largely digital
process anywhere anybody with a paper
certificate that can be now handled
quite easily and digitized that's a
natural progression of someone we've
seen I guess the exciting thing there
for private investors might be voting in
agms directly maybe one logical
consequence of that as the next step the
early stage investment I think is
clearly going to be very interesting
this five percent pledge that Mr Hunt's
looking to nudge the the the
um Pension funds towards although I
guess the tricky bit there is if we're
seeing that high risk Investments
guarantee your high risk High returns
then they're not really high risk
Investments are they so I think we need
to be a little bit careful there and
also the pooling of funds to create big
super funds that we see in Australia or
Canada to cut fees out well I'm sure
that's going to be seen as a good thing
for those people whose money are in
those funds yeah Russ always good to see
you thanks for joining me today
still to come here on business live
we're going to be looking into new
research which suggests that more than a
third of all Global mergers and
Acquisitions are leaked don't go away
[Music]
well they've risen to 17 000 which is an
all-time high and we expect them to keep
increasing so about about 26 000 by 2040
and what's behind it is it's actually
really interesting because it relates to
social trends skin cancer takes a long
time to develop so what we're seeing is
actually the effect of UV exposure
potentially many decades ago in the 60s
as you said there was an increase in
package holidays a much lower awareness
that UV rays could cause skin cancer a
much lower sunscreen usage so these are
all factors and we have an aging
population so there's a bulge in the
over 55s which is also contributing to
the increase in natural numbers
definitely what we saw since the 60s is
there was a trend towards being tanned
being a positive thing and so
um but also sunscreen usage was much
lower than as you said so over the years
I think that's changed our
recommendation very much is for SPF 15
at the very least
and that's when it's applied
um regularly according to the
instructions generously some people
recommend SPF 30 as well to take into
account the fact that a lot of people
don't apply sunscreen as generously and
regularly as they should but they've
been really great advances in treatment
for skin cancer so now skin cancer most
skin cancers are just excised so you
don't require chemotherapy or
immunotherapy and often an outpatient
appointment as well we think about nine
in ten Cancers and nine in ten skin
cancers are preventable so they're
related to UV exposure so hopefully over
the very long term as sunscreen usage
become you know has become more
prevalent we would like to see that
curve curve changing but for now I think
people can be reassured that if if they
spot any changes in their skin do go to
their GP
um and actually if it is does turn out
to be skin cancer it will be very
treatable
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back now what are the criticisms
most frequently made of generative AI
models like chat GPT is that some of the
content they produce can be inaccurate
well that highlights the importance of
feeding such models with reliable and
trustworthy data and has led to a rise
in so-called data intelligence companies
or one such business is Elation whose
customers here in the UK include
Sainsbury's marks and Spencer and very
who joining me now is Sachin sangani the
chief executive of elation such and
welcome to you thank you for joining me
it's such an unsociable hour um what are
the challenges involved in testing the
accuracy of a data set
well first of all it's getting the right
data the challenge that many of these
Enterprises has have is that their data
is strewn across so many different data
sets and so many different databases
that often what they find is that the
data scientists can't even find the data
in the first place and then once they do
find this data what they discover is
that they can't understand whether the
data set is fit for purpose how the data
was produced where it came from and so
one might expect that this data is all
organized and accessible but quite
contrary to the to the case many of
these Enterprises have a lot of
disorganized information
is this a case of businesses cutting
corners or is it just that this is an
incredibly complex matter to get to
grips with
far more the latter than the former you
find that many of these organizations
have grown up over 20 30 40 years in
their infrastructure Information
Technology infrastructure the
consequence of that is that you find so
many different versions of information
so many different versions of technology
and with all these different versions
it's really difficult to navigate all
this information a little bit like
looking around the web but not having
Google you have so many different web
pages produced over so much time but
hard to understand what's where or
what's trustworthy unless you have a
central search engine what are the
regulations governing data provision
well there are not very many specific
around data provisioning there are some
certainly around privacy the best known
one of that is gdpr uh which we all
which you know certainly was The
Godfather to many other regulations
around the world including here in the
United States there are others in
Industry specifically in the United
States here we have HIPAA which stands
for healthcare information Privacy Act
but there aren't very many that sort of
globally I'm an industry agnostic basis
govern the management of data and
certainly not the data for artificial
intelligence models as is being
contemplated in the EU right now
and very briefly you've committed uh you
completed a Series E funding round last
November you raised 340 million dollars
how have you been putting that to use
well research and development is of
course absolutely critical in this
market in this space there is so much
that AI brings to bear in both
understanding data and being able to
describe it at scale enabling people to
use data better because often data is
inscrutable to so many different people
who are trying to use it on a day-to-day
basis and then of course finally data is
absolutely critical in feeding the
models that other practitioners are
trying to use and so r d is obviously
where we're putting together most of our
dollars of course there are efforts to
globalize the firm both in the EU and
abroad in APAC but that's certainly
secondary all right such and we have to
leave it there thanks again for joining
me at such an early hour I do appreciate
it
great to be here and thank you for
having me
now details of more than a third of all
Global mergers and Acquisitions leak
according to research published today by
age advisors the global strategic
Communications Advisory Group Well the
report suggests that in deals negotiated
in Western Europe and Asia are
significantly more likely to leak ahead
of their official announcement than
those in the United States it also
suggests that some sectors such as
Aerospace transport and Retail are
significantly leakier than others who
are joining me now is Neil Bennett he's
Global chief executive of H advisors sir
Neil welcome to you um chatting to Russ
bold before the break days he said only
a third
well I have to say a 35 of all these 267
deals around the world worth two billion
or more that we analyzed that's 35 of
them when you consider that everyone who
leaks is leaky price sensitive
information so therefore they're at very
least breaching regulations and often in
many cases in many jurisdictions the law
that's a lot of leaking it is I mean
there isn't a leaking itself is not a
crime though it's when you trade on that
information yes I think the well it
depends on jurisdiction by jurisdiction
but handling prices sensitive
information at the very least is a
breach of trust and so that's a lot now
as we say in the report we've cut it
lots of different ways uh and Asia
Pacific is the leakiest region followed
by Western Europe uh America's
significantly less leaky other things
that have shown uh some things you might
expect big deals leak a lot more than
smaller deals uh but the sectors are
interesting so a very high proportion of
Aerospace deals which surprised us even
more than deals in the media sector
which are pretty leaky compared to
property where it seems very little to a
few deals leak and you could say that's
because people are rather less
interested in them yeah maybe well I
mean you've worked in and around Capital
markets for decades do you think this
problem's got worse over time
I think uh each show I don't think it's
got worse but it shows that despite the
best efforts of regulators it's still a
significant issue and that all companies
when planning a big piece of M A need to
uh include it in their in in a factor it
into their negotiations and their
preparation I mean the thing that uh
really jumped out of me with big
transactions 25 billion dollars plus 80
percent of them Lee I guess that's just
a function of the number of advisors
involved exactly I think that is because
so many people get involved in a big
deal that uh the the the the sort of
risk factor goes up exponentially so why
do you think the US is less leaky is it
because they've just got tougher
regulation I think that might be part of
it and the SEC is a genuinely scary
regulator I think the other thing we're
looking at deals over two billion
dollars or more so at the smaller end a
two billion dollar deal in some markets
let's say the UK is quite a big deal a
two billion dollar deal in America is a
bit humdrum maybe people are just not as
interested yeah that's interesting
cracking I mean we could do with a few
more two billion uh plus deals in the UK
right now exactly I mean do you get the
sense though that many people are
actually trading on this information
when it leaks well clearly share price
moves and when the leagues happen what
we've also shown is there's an enormous
surge in Twitter traffic so the word
gets out uh prices move uh and very
often you know either one party or the
other then has to put out a confirmation
statement to cleanse the market so the
risk is that people are trading but uh
so that has to be factored into a real
headache for people like you well as I
say the the what what is the solution to
this for people you know for companies
planning a deal is to paraphrase Tony
Blair preparation preparation
preparation don't leave it to hope and
trust that people stay quiet but ensure
you have a plan
to deal with it all right now we've got
to leave it there good to see you this
morning
that's it from me I'm back again at half
past four this afternoon do you stay
with us so after this it's Lee balletto
coming up off the short break see you
later
[Music]